[Música]
los países de América Latina han
defendido una supuesta neutralidad
frente a la guerra en Ucrania la mayoría
de los líderes de la región ni han
condenado a Rusia ni al kremlin por su
invasión y tampoco han respaldado
abiertamente al presidente ucraniano
está neutralidad es un arma de doble
filo porque por un lado no han enviado a
Ucrania municiones ni armamento ruso que
tienen a pesar de que Estados Unidos ha
presionado mucho para que sí lo hagan al
igual que Alemania Pero por otro lado
gigantes latinoamericanos como Brasil
México y Argentina continúan sus
relaciones comerciales con Moscú de
hecho América Latina no ha respaldado
las sanciones económicas que Washington
y la Unión Europea han impuesto contra
Rusia todo esto a pesar de que la
mayoría de los países latinos sí
respaldaron las resoluciones más
importantes que se han votado hasta
ahora en la asamblea general de la ONU
condenando la guerra y los votos han
sido los mismos tanto en la resolución
del 2 de marzo de 2022 con la deploró la
agresión rusa como con la del 24 de
marzo en la que respaldó la ayuda
humanitaria a Ucrania y exigieron el
cese inmediato de las hostilidades más
de 15 países latinos votaron a favor
incluso México fue junto a Francia uno
de los impulsores de la segunda
resolución y aunque Brasil también votó
afirmativamente luego matizó su postura
dejando Claro que sí apoyaba la ayuda
humanitaria pero que estaba en contra
del lenguaje político y divisivo como lo
llamó del otro lado hubo cuatro países
latinoamericanos que siempre se
abstuvieron Bolivia cuba El Salvador y
Nicaragua mientras que Venezuela se
ausentó en ambas votaciones todo esto
muestra la postura ambivalente que ha
tenido América Latina sobre la guerra en
Ucrania y en ese contexto es que el ex
comisionado de paz de Colombia Sergio
Jaramillo está liderando la iniciativa
aguanta Ucrania para marcar un apoyo
decidido a favor de kiev Pero qué tan
determinante es un respaldo latino por
ejemplo en la guerra de la información y
realmente tendría una incidencia
significativa la cantidad de armas o
municiones que se podrían enviar desde
la región que ganan y que pierden los
países latinos en materia económica y
políticas y apoyan abiertamente a
Ucrania o a Rusia todo esto es lo que
vamos a discutir hoy en el debate de
France 24 para analizar el tema hemos
invitado a Héctor abad facio Lince
escritor y periodista colombiano quien
respalda la propuesta aguanta a Ucrania
y también está con nosotros desde Ciudad
de México yorelvi Calixto maestra en
asuntos internacionales con especialidad
en política ellos les doy la bienvenida
Pero antes de comenzar les recuerdo a
quienes nos están viendo que también son
parte del debate dejen sus comentarios y
preguntas a través de las redes sociales
nos encuentran en Twitter Facebook e
Instagram como arroba franz24 raya al
piso ese y la etiqueta es numeral el
debate f-24 Mis cuentas además las
encuentran como María cl Aguirre no
olviden que todos los contenidos de
nuestro programa están disponibles en
Apple podcast Spotify deezer y TuneIn
Ahora sí quiero comenzar con nuestros
invitados primero dándole la bienvenida
doctorabat fascio Gracias por estar con
nosotros y lo primero que le quiero
preguntar es qué tanto le sirve a
América Latina esta supuesta neutralidad
bueno ante todo gracias por invitarme
yo no he pensado en los intereses de
América Latina con la neutralidad Me
parece que históricamente
esto no ha sido beneficioso América
Latina fue neutral al comienzo de la
Segunda Guerra Mundial trató de no estar
ni con las potencias del eje ni con la
ni con la alianza que finalmente derrotó
a Hitler y solo cuando vieron muy
claramente que la guerra la iban a
perder los nazis pues vinieron algunos
países de América Latina que habían
incluso coqueteado con con Hitler a
sumarse a la alianza occidental contra
la peor amenaza para la democracia que
ha tenido probablemente el mundo la
situación ahora es parecida a pesar de
estas declaraciones en la ONU contra la
guerra Pues los gobiernos incluso cuando
ha habido cambios de extrema derecha a
izquierda como ocurrió en Brasil
han cambiado su posición prefieren
quedarse en declaraciones a medias lo
mismo ha pasado con el cambio de poder
en Colombia de un presidente de derecha
como Duque a uno de izquierda como Petro
yo creo que históricamente esta
neutralidad si bien es cómoda si bien no
no nos compromete no nos obligan a nada
también nos hace parecer como países
indiferentes ante el gran sufrimiento y
esto es lo que más nos afecta a nosotros
a los del movimiento de aguanta Ucrania
lo que nosotros resaltamos es el
sufrimiento de la población civil
ucraniana y el atentado que significa
para la independencia de un país
soberano como Ucrania que sufra una
invasión de parte de una potencia
Imperial sumamente más poderosa y
precisamente lo que usted comentaba lo
vamos a analizar después a profundidad
con aguanta Ucrania Qué significa esta
propuesta y también ese cambio de
gobierno concretamente en Brasil Cómo se
ha visto frente a la guerra en Ucrania
quiero pasar entonces a darle la
bienvenida y agradecerle por estar con
nosotros en el debate a yurel vi Calixto
y hacerle También la misma pregunta de
qué le sirve América Latina Esta
neutralidad es una posición histórica
conveniente como ya lo decía Héctor o
ganamos algo o perdemos algo frente a
esto
Pues antes que nada Muchísimas gracias
por la invitación y un saludo al Foro
que nos está viendo pues sí
efectivamente como dice Héctor también
es una posición histórica que América
Latina ha tenido no al final tiene esta
visión de ser un país que fue colonizado
Y de alguna otra manera siente esta
empatía con Ucrania sin embargo ya no
estamos en ese periodo histórico ya
estamos en otro periodo histórico y no
podemos como seguir con estos
antecedentes y vivir en el pasado
de qué le sirve o qué no le sirve creo
que ahorita y lo que deberíamos analizar
es más bien qué es lo que va a pasar si
se mantiene no en una posición neutral
si los estados empiezan y los países
empiezan a tener una posición que sea
contundente ya sea A favor o en contra
Tenemos que tener en cuenta que todas
las cuestiones que tienen que ver con
economía con temas militares y con
política está totalmente ligado a las
decisiones que tomen los países y esto
llevar consecuencias directamente a los
países es decir si un país se posiciona
fuertemente A favor o en contra está
dando la imagen de que está A favor o en
contra del otro país No si si estás a
favor de Estados Unidos o estás en
contra de Rusia o viceversa y esto
podría traer consecuencias directas a
las importaciones a las exportaciones a
la posición política a la posición
incluso geoestratégica no por ejemplo
hablando de México que México en un
supuesto decidiera el presidente Andrés
Manuel López Obrador hablar públicamente
y hacerlo a favor de Rusia no el
contexto en el que nos encontraríamos
con nuestro país vecino no sería
cualquier cosa entonces creo que también
mucho de estas decisiones de no tomar
una decisión contundente de A lo mejor
Mostrar un poco más de neutralidad
tienen que ver con estas posiciones
También tenemos que tomar en cuenta que
venimos de unos años de pandemia que
económicamente han pegado al mercado
global Entonces no podemos seguir
tomando
tan tajantes que pudieran además
incrementar la inflación ya existente es
por eso que creo que los estados han
estado fluctuando entre decidir si a
veces están a favor si a veces están en
contra si a veces son neutrales Incluso
el mismo México Brasil lo ha hecho por
lo tanto también Creo que están
analizando y están pensando la situación
en la que se van encontrando las
negociaciones que van de por medio
justamente con toda esta tema de la
economía que tiene que ver mucho en las
relaciones internacionales
Y ustedes mencionaron unos países que
tienen algo en común Colombia Argentina
y México ellos traen los presidentes
Gustavo Petro Alberto Fernández y Andrés
Manuel López Obrador se han negado a
enviar armas a Ucrania argumentando que
están a favor de la paz y los tres han
tenido este mismo discurso y de hecho
tal como lo dijo yorelvin la posición de
Argentina es venimos de una pandemia que
nos ha desolado no hay justificación
ahora para defender una guerra o para
que el mundo entre en una nueva guerra a
pesar de esta postura a favor de la paz
el presidente de Alberto Fernández
estaba en Moscú el día que el presidente
Vladimir Putin declaró la invasión a
Rusia y él estaba precisamente para
abrir esos canales y estando allí en una
rueda de prensa dijo que argentina se
podría convertir en la puerta de entrada
para Rusia a América Latina le quiero
entonces preguntar a Héctor abad qué
piensa y cómo se une a la postura que
usted ya nos había comentado que no ha
cambiado mucho ni respecto al
expresidente colombiano Iván Duque y
ahora el presidente Gustavo Petro es
real o no esto a favor de la Paz o es
una manera de un poco esconder una
postura real frente a la guerra
bueno pocos días antes del presidente
argentino también también había estado
en Moscú el presidente bolsonaro de
Brasil realmente yo creo que había
cierta simpatía muy clara por ejemplo en
un personaje como bolsonaro claramente
autoritario y con tendencias muy
marcadas al militarismo y a la tiranía a
sentir simpatía por un líder como Putin
en el caso de Argentina la cuestión es
más de clientela es más de intereses
comerciales y querer diversificar sus
exportaciones y sus importaciones y
tener un Aliado en en Rusia como es como
si fuera realmente Rusia una gran
potencia económica que en realidad no lo
es Rusia es en realidad una gran
potencia militar una potencia nuclear
con con unas armas un poco envejecidas
como lo ha demostrado esta misma
invasión a Ucrania pero sin duda una
potencia militar
de primer orden
yo creo que esta postura un poco cómoda
de los gobiernos de derecha y luego de
los de izquierda de declararse neutrales
o pacifistas a ultranza Pues sí es es lo
que es lo que quieren hacer es lo cómodo
pero a mí me parece que la sociedad
civil puede en vista de que los
gobiernos no dicen nada y parece no
afectarlos la crisis humanitaria que se
vive en Ucrania yo creo que la sociedad
civil es lo que está ocurriendo puede
moverse al menos para manifestar una
solidaridad de tipo humanitario los
presidentes Pues sí ellos manejan sus
propias agendas lo demuestran el de
México el de Argentina los de Brasil
ahora el de Colombia también pero yo
creo que los ciudadanos afortunadamente
disfrutamos aquí de libertades que no se
disfrutan en Rusia y podemos manifestar
nuestra opinión sin que nos envenenen o
nos metan en la cárcel como en cambio Si
ocurre en en Rusia afortunadamente
todavía podemos hablar los civiles a
favor al menos de la sociedad civil
Entonces los civiles defendiendo un poco
también esta sociedad civil y
defendiendo o apoyando y haciendo cosas
para revertir la crisis humanitaria y a
nivel gubernamental usted menciona algo
que le quiero preguntar a llore elvi es
de un lado han tenido una posición
clientelista en América Latina un poco
para favorecer la economía y los
intercambios comerciales con Rusia pero
como usted bien lo dice Rusia no es un
gran Aliado de América Latina en
términos económicos como sí lo es
Estados Unidos por ejemplo que ha
presionado el presidente de Colombia
Gustavo Petro lo dijo explícitamente que
Estados Unidos le había pedido que le
vendieran helicópteros que ya no
utilizaban que eran helicópteros rusos y
que se los pasaran a Ucrania Pues los
ucranianos los habían manejar mucho
mejor que otras armas occidentales y
Gustavo Petro se negó diciendo que
estaba a favor de la Paz Le quiero
preguntar Entonces qué tanto es
intereses clientelistas y que tanto
pueden resistir la presión de Estados
Unidos en materia económica y política y
además teniendo un sentimiento en toda
la región que desde el la propuesta
aguanta Ucrania han declarado como anti
americanismo
Pues yo insisto creo que cada una de
estas decisiones va a tener que ver
directamente con el momento en el que se
pida es decir es un hecho que Estados
Unidos tiene una influencia no en
América Latina y por eso también somos
aliados comerciales O sea la cercanía
tiene muchísimo que ver pero si bien los
estados no han decidido tomar una
posición es justamente por eso porque no
solamente tienen ganancias comerciales
con Estados Unidos sino también con
Rusia aunque sean en menor medida por lo
tanto entrar en esta discusión de con
quién estar no nos remota un poco a lo
que pasábamos después de la Segunda
Guerra Mundial qué es lo que puede pasar
yo creo que va a ser con base en lo que
vaya pasando en el momento en las
negociaciones que en ese momento
paralelas al conflicto ucraniano estén
pasando en términos comerciales y en
términos políticos lo que vaya
conviniendo a los intereses de los
estados es la decisión que van a ir
tomando No por nada justamente se han
estado manteniendo en este debate entre
sí ser neutrales si en ciertas asambleas
generales Naciones Unidas han por
ejemplo votado no al cese a la
hostilidad al retiro de las fuerzas Como
lo hicieron en algún momento Brasil y
México entonces mucho tiene que ver
justamente este tema El económico y el
político y es claro que también las
ideologías aquí pues van a ser muy
importantes Por qué Porque pues
Venezuela por ejemplo sabemos no esta
esta alianza que tiene directamente con
Rusia que muy difícilmente por un tema
ideológico propio de del país se va a
mostrar a favor no abierta directamente
con Estados Unidos ahora como lo dice mi
compañero Héctor Claro ya como civiles
dentro de toda esta región y dentro de
todos estos países podemos mostrar una
posición respecto al conflicto
hay que tener en cuenta que en cualquier
guerra siempre siempre los daños
colaterales Lamentablemente van
directamente a lo que es la población
civil mujeres niños
desgraciadamente también la violación a
derechos humanos lo cual por supuesto es
preocupante sin embargo
sí no Discúlpame que la que la
interrumpa pero quiero preguntarle por
algo y es antes de pasar a esta parte
del papel de los civiles la última
pregunta frente a los gobiernos Y es que
tan significativas pueden ser las armas
que América Latina pueda enviar a
Ucrania y lo digo porque concretamente
el presidente colombiano se negó a
entregar helicópteros soviéticos mi8 y m
y 17 y por parte de Brasil se negaron a
entregar municiones de los tanques
leopardos se entregaron a dar tanques
blindados guaraní y también se negaron a
dar municiones que pedía Alemania
Realmente si América Latina enviar armas
esto cambiaría en algo la guerra
no no podría cambiar mucho la guerra
porque América Latina realmente no tiene
una industria militar tan fuerte como la
tiene por ejemplo Estados Unidos y
justamente tú les mencionado simplemente
el armamento que se está pidiendo es
armamento de origen ruso o de origen
americano en dado caso es decir no son
armamentos que sean construidos
directamente en América Latina o con
tecnología de América Latina no va a ser
significativo aquí Más bien es un
discurso indirecto de El estar mandando
armas es estar poniendo una posición de
alguna otra manera por debajo de la mesa
estás Entonces a favor de un lado o del
otro por lo tanto estás apoyando ese
movimiento y ahora sí quiero ir con
Héctor Héctor cuéntenos un poco más de
esta iniciativa aguanta Ucrania que
Sergio Jaramillo habló directamente de
ella en el high festival en Cartagena
hace unas pocas semanas como ha avanzado
Quiénes se han sumado escritores por
ejemplo como el cubano Leonardo padura
la respaldan Pero qué más ha funcionado
aquí Y cómo esto ayuda realmente a la
población civil de Ucrania
Bueno sí como usted dice esta fue una
iniciativa del ex comisionado de paz
Sergio Jaramillo el que firmó por el
gobierno de Colombia la paz con las Farc
él él se puso en contacto conmigo y con
muchas otras personas para saber nuestra
posición sobre la Guerra de Ucrania y
nos pidió si nos uníamos a esta campaña
de de civiles no de personas con
responsabilidades políticas en apoyo a
la sociedad ucraniana la consideración
general es que esta fue una invasión una
invasión de tipo Imperial en pleno Siglo
21 Putin quiere de algún modo restaurar
los viejos imperios rusos bien sea el
más reciente de la Unión soviética de la
que formaba parte Ucrania como una de
las repúblicas
socialistas soviéticas que conformaban
este Imperio que no se veía como imperio
por ser socialista o incluso restaurar
el viejo imperio zarista de los el viejo
imperio zarista
nuestra posición ha sido Clara
simplemente vemos Esta invasión como lo
que es una invasión y una guerra una
guerra provocada por la agresión de
Putin no es una operación militar
especial como ordena Putin que se diga y
que tienen que decir todos los medios de
comunicación rusa es rusos es una
invasión con todas las reglas Él junto
tropas durante meses en las fronteras de
Ucrania creyó que iba a poder hacer una
blitzk al estilo de Hitler es decir una
Guerra Relámpago en la que en pocas
semanas o pocos días iba a conquistar
incluso la capital iba a cambiar el
gobierno e iba a incorporar a Ucrania
a Rusia como ya lo había hecho en el
2014 con la Península de crimea en ese
momento occidente incluso Estados Unidos
Pues de dientes para afuera protestaron
pero no le pasó nada Putin y con su
Campaña en el este de Ucrania y ahora
desató la invasión total la posición de
muchos de nosotros que hemos hablado en
esta campaña de aguanto ahí Ucrania es
anti Imperial
antimilitarista anti colonialista
América Latina como como decía antes la
profesora Calixto
ha sufrido muchísimas invasiones de
parte de Estados Unidos por ejemplo
antes de de España o incluso o incluso
de Francia en las antillas y y conoce la
importancia de la no intervención de
otros países en nuestras sociedades en
nuestros países independientes
hay muchas personas de gobiernos que
apoyan a Rusia como del gobierno como
venezolanos que sienten más de cerca lo
que es el poderío de Putin que nos
apoyan también muchos nicaragüenses
muchos de ellos En el exilio que sienten
también más de cerca la alianza
Alianza no contra Natura sino es
bastante natural entre Ortega y Putin
ellos también sienten con mucha Claridad
este dolor de de los de los ucranianos y
y se han Unido escritores músicos
actores directores de cine actrices en
fin ha sido un movimiento que ahora cada
vez se abre más a otras profesiones
usted mencionó dos puntos que han sido
vitales digamos en esa guerra discursiva
si se trata de una invasión por parte de
Rusia como lo ha defendido Ucrania o si
es una operación militar especial como
lo dice Rusia sin embargo es Claro que
en la mayoría por lo menos de medios
occidentales el término invasión es el
primordial y en esta guerra de la
información creo que el presidente
ha hecho un papel de crear una narrativa
desde el inicio desde Cómo habla cada
cuanto habla cómo viste y en esta guerra
me atrevería a decir que el balance está
más hacia Ucrania en ese sentido Por qué
entonces la necesidad de uno de una
propuesta como aguanta Ucrania si en el
lado informativo y discursivo y
narrativo la balanza parece inclinarse
más hacia Ucrania
Pues porque no es solo crear una
narrativa sino tratar de que la
narrativa se corresponda con la verdad y
con la realidad lo que se ve es que no
hay una agresión de Ucrania a Rusia lo
que se ve es que no hay muertos civiles
en Rusia lo que se ve es que no están
sufriendo agua y frío porque les
bombardean las centrales eléctricas en
Rusia no todo ocurre en Ucrania entonces
no es una narrativa que divulga un gran
actor que es el presidente sino que es
una narración de hechos que se pueden
comprobar y que se ven se puede ver que
han salido millones de ucranianos de su
territorio se puede ver que miles y
miles de niños de viejos de mujeres y
también de soldados naturalmente han
fallecido en esta en esta guerra se
puede ver que llamar a esto una
operación militar especial sí que es una
narrativa bastante
indiscutible cuando se la compara con la
realidad bueno Y también por eso la
importancia de estas propuestas como
aguanta Ucrania un poco para mostrar
esto que no es narrativa sino una
narración de los hechos como usted mismo
lo dice Pero estas iniciativas no Solo
han surgido de la población civil sino
que también se han dado a nivel
diplomático y lo vemos ahora la Unión
Europea presionando cada vez más América
Latina para que salga de esa neutralidad
y apoye abiertamente a Ucrania y lo digo
precisamente porque se va a venir
ahorita en julio de este año la reunión
entre la celac que es la comunidad de
Estados latinoamericanos y caribeños y
la Unión Europea una reunión que no
sucede desde 2015 y desde antes los
cancilleres y los ministros de
relaciones exteriores de la celac y de
la Unión Europea comenzaron a reunirse
un poco para preparar esto y lo hicieron
en octubre en Argentina el año pasado
Sin embargo en esta declaración
No hay ninguna mención directa ni a
Ucrania ni a Rusia ni a favor ni en
contra como lo esperaba la Unión Europea
a pesar de que los latinoamericanos y
los europeos si dijeron apoyar los
derechos humanos y los principios de la
carta de Naciones Unidas Le quiero
preguntar entonces a llore elvi Qué
tanta presión está ejerciendo la Unión
Europea y cuál es su interés en que
América Latina marque una postura
decisiva frente a la guerra
pues América Latina al final Como lo
menciona Héctor tiene este sentimiento
no histórico de afinidad por el tema de
Invasión por lo tanto también y es una
región importante Por lo tanto por
supuesto que buscarían no tener
definitivamente una posición Clara y que
no estuviera
vacilando de un lado a otro sin embargo
hay que tener en cuenta también algo en
este hecho histórico que la guerra no
surgió del de un día a otro No no es que
Putin un día se levantó y dijo voy a
invadir Ucrania y vamos a hacer la
guerra ya había antecedentes pudin había
dicho desde mucho tiempo antes que lo
otan estaba haciendo No una un
acercamiento hacia Rusia hacia Ucrania
perdón y que Putin esto no lo iba a
permitir No él condenó mucho meses antes
el hecho de que si si lo tan seguía
haciendo esta presión hacia Ucrania él
iba a hacer algo entonces
también hay que tener en cuenta que pues
justamente está ya estas advertencias se
venían haciendo desde un año antes de la
invasión Ucrania sin embargo Estados
Unidos y la otan siguió presionando para
que Ucrania fuera parte de del otan y al
ser así pues Putin lo que hizo fue al
final cumplir esa palabra el decir yo
les advertí que si la otan seguía siendo
presencia en una zona que para mí es una
zona de influencia que es una zona
geopolítica no Incluso en alguna
declaración lo llamó su patio trasero
Pues yo iba también tomar no eh una
posición respecto a eso es como si por
ejemplo Rusia hubiera decidido también
con México decir que quiere poner en
Tijuana
una central nuclear obviamente Estados
Unidos no se va a quedar con los brazos
cruzados porque estamos hablando de
entonces entrar directamente a una zona
geopolítica y de influencia del otro por
lo tanto si bien una guerra jamás va a
ser deseable y siempre va a tener
consecuencias como violación a derechos
humanos como no donde los civiles se van
a ver más afectados pues también hay que
tener en consideración que el hecho que
un país decida entrar a una zona
influencia de otro va a traer
consecuencias Sí o sí pero más allá de
este contexto de la guerra o Cómo
comenzó Le quiero preguntar es el
interés que tiene la Unión Europea para
que los países latinoamericanos se
muestren A favor o en contra y lo digo
precisamente porque en América Latina
está el 22% del petróleo de las reservas
probadas de todo el mundo además Aquí
hay una riqueza también de gas y de
litio que es lo necesario para construir
las baterías y también de hidrógeno
verde en un momento en el que la Unión
Europea está haciendo un tránsito a
energías más limpias y el hidrógeno
verde se plantea como una solución y de
hecho todo esto litio hidrógeno verde
fue lo que pactó shorts en su visita el
canciller Alemán Argentina chile y
Brasil Mi pregunta es entonces hay un
interés económico detrás de esta postura
Europea para que los latinos apoyen más
abiertamente a Ucrania
Sí claro siempre va a haber una posición
y era lo que yo hablaba en un inicio el
hecho de una guerra no quita que detrás
siempre va a haber intereses económicos
puede haber intereses militares puede
haber intereses de importaciones o
exportaciones Y en este caso como tú lo
mencionaste estamos hablando de energía
estamos hablando lo que mueve un país no
el tema también que está Rusia con el
gas entonces obviamente de alguna otra
manera todos estos temas comerciales
todo este tema de recursos naturales no
va a entrar dentro de la discusión
también es por eso que no es tan fácil
para un país
latinoamericano tomar una posición
directamente hacia un lado hacia el otro
por qué Porque va a implicar también
incluso que se pudieran quedar sin por
ejemplo algún tipo de reserva digo lo
vimos esta guerra en Ucrania ha pegado a
América Latina por la falta por ejemplo
de cereales o el incremento a los
precios de los mismos
esta economía global que ya está
entrelazada es difícil que un conflicto
que se dé una parte del mundo no afecte
a los demás y por lo tanto hablando de
energías por presupuesto por supuesto
hay intereses detrás de esta guerra de
que no se queden los países sin
justamente estos no estos minerales que
no se encuentra directamente en sus
estados que los necesitan exportar de
otro lado
Sí y quiero pasar ahora con Héctor para
preguntarle de nuevo sobre esta postura
de la sociedad civil en países donde los
gobiernos tienen una postura
supuestamente neutral y usted había
dicho el caso ha sido prácticamente el
mismo con los expresidentes con el
expresidente de Brasil Jair bolsonaro y
con el actual mandatario Luis Ignacio
Lula da Silva y de hecho el presidente
ruso Vladimir Putin justo antes de la
segunda vuelta electoral en Brasil dijo
que le daba lo mismo si ganaba bolsonaro
Lula porque los dos tenían la misma
postura frente a Rusia y abiertamente
dijo Brasil es el Aliado más importante
que tiene Rusia en América Latina
teniendo esto en cuenta que tanta
presión puede ejercer la ciudadanía de
un país como Brasil para hacer que su
gobierno sí tome una postura o se
acerque o se aleje más de Rusia o de
Ucrania y también lo vemos como usted lo
mencionó con escritores y artistas de
Nicaragua Venezuela Cuba que han
respaldado aguanta Ucrania Qué tanta
presión pueden ejercer ellos sobre sus
propios gobiernos
pues María Clara lo que yo creo Es que
lo que los civiles podemos decir es que
los intereses no son solamente
comerciales económicos
o de armamentos los intereses son
también de cómo queremos vivir
lo que pasó en Ucrania con la rebelión
la revolución del maidán Cuando un
presidente fue elegido con la bandera de
que iba a intentar que Ucrania se uniera
a la Unión Europea y él los traicionó
después de salir elegido
Esa fue lo que levantó a la sociedad
civil ucraniana Por qué Porque me parece
muy natural que la mayoría de los
ucranianos prefieran vivir en un en
regímenes que se parezcan más a los de
la Unión Europea como los de Alemania
Francia Italia España Portugal etcétera
que querer vivir en una sociedad que se
parezca más a la rusa donde no hay
libertad para los homosexuales para los
transexuales donde ellos se creen la
patria la gran Santa Rusia que protege
la moral del mundo que en occidente se
está degradando la sociedad civil lo que
está impulsando es que no se piense solo
en términos económicos o en términos
armamentistas como la otan y el bloque y
el bloque ruso sino que se piense en la
población civil y en lo que la población
civil quiere y lo que quiere es vivir
con libertad poder escoger a sus líderes
y a sus gobernantes libremente poder
tener una prensa libre poder hablar
libremente por la televisión por la
radio de eso se trata de valores
fundamentales de libertad que en este
momento defiende la sociedad ucraniana y
también el gobierno ucraniano Entonces
no Solo lo importante son los intereses
económicos
Ucrania no es un peón ni de occidente ni
debe ser un peón de Putin Ucrania debe
ser una República independiente como
como lo son la mayoría de la república
latinoamericanas y a eso es lo que
intentamos nosotros desde la sociedad
civil decirle al mundo y también Así se
hace manifiesto Cuál es el tipo de
sociedad en la que preferimos vivir una
sociedad más abierta una sociedad donde
las libertades personales se respeten o
una sociedad como la rusa donde estas
libertades personales están
permanentemente amenazadas y conculcadas
y ya para ir cerrando nuestro debate
quiero comenzar precisamente de nuevo
con Héctor y hacer un resumen general un
balance general de qué opina usted de la
postura de América Latina tanto de la
sociedad como de los gobiernos frente a
la guerra en Ucrania Cuál es el balance
de que usted daría bueno la postura de
los gobiernos me parece una postura de
un equilibrismo
inútil me parece me parece de una
tibieza
No sé lo tibio En estos casos me parece
triste me parece tratar de darle la
espalda a la guerra más importante y más
decisiva que hay hoy en el mundo
y no tanto por el hecho de que manden
armas o no Porque como decía antes la
profesora calisto y usted misma María
Clara el armamento latinoamericano
Afortunadamente no es importante Ojalá
fuéramos todos como como Costa Rica
países sin ejército y que no tuviéramos
nada que ofrecerle en términos
armamentísticos ni ni a Ucrania ni a
Putin ni a nadie no es por ese lado yo
diría que que lo triste es que no haya
unos gobiernos y una sociedad civil más
comprometida con valores fundamentales
como los valores desde la de la
independencia de los de los de los
distintos países de del final de La Era
colonial que Putin trata de vivir y de Y
de lo que realmente nos importa A todos
aquí o en Europa o en Estados Unidos y
es cómo queremos vivir la misma pregunta
para usted Cuál es este balance que
usted hace y sobre todo también
retomando un poco lo que decía Héctor
entre los valores fundamentales a
defender y que tanto es la postura de la
ciudadanía a favor de estos valores y de
los gobiernos respecto a la guerra en
Ucrania
claro Pues mira Claro que en un mundo
ideal lo lo mejor sería que Las Guerras
no existieran no que que esta garantía
los derechos humanos se diera en todas
las poblaciones y en todas las
sociedades que la protección a los niños
a las mujeres no siempre estuviera y
fuera el Baluarte de todos los estados
sin embargo no es la realidad en la que
vivimos desgraciadamente y y difícil va
a cambiar y creo que también mucho sin
justificar pero mucho del balance que
hacen no de este costo oportunidad los
estados y los líderes de los estados es
saber que si toman una decisión radical
Cómo puede afectar directamente a su
estado Cómo puede afectar directamente a
su población o a su economía o a su
política poniendo muy particular por
ejemplo el caso de México si López
Obrador tomar una decisión muy
contundente respecto a apoyar pongamos
el ejemplo de Rusia cómo nos va a
afectar directamente cuando ya tenemos
un problema importante Por ejemplo ya
con el crimen organizado no tenemos un
tema de inseguridad que incrementando
estos últimos años entonces un problema
mayor no con una potencia De ese tamaño
con un poder económico con un poder
militar de ese tamaño Cómo podría
afectar directamente a sus connacionales
No es tan fácil tomar una postura
radical claro y no es tan fácil
precisamente como usted lo dice por las
afectaciones que podría tener en los
Estados Más allá de si hacen realmente
un cambio no en la guerra en Ucrania es
más factores internos como lo decía
Héctor de valores fundamentales de la
ciudadanía actora facio Lince y a llore
Elvis Calixto les agradezco por estar
con nosotros en el debate y a ustedes
nuestra audiencia continúen con más en
France 24
[Música]